the PlayStation 4 slim recently came out
and you might be wondering what the
differences are between it and the
original ps4 I'm here to explain the
underlying specs of the slim are largely
the same as the original playstation 4
model this means you shouldn't expect to
see an increase in graphical performance
but there are some notable differences
worth pointing out the most noticeable
one is that the ps4 slim is well slimmer
it's 11 by 10 by 1.5 inch chassis is
actually smaller in every dimension
compared to the originals 12 by 10 by
eight point two inch case it's also 1.6
pounds lighter weighing four point six
pounds the slim also has rounded corners
yeah it kind of loses its edgy look here
and you can argue that it looks a little
boring but it also has a simple and
clean aesthetic there are some under the
hood improvements as well the slim now
supports 5 gigahertz Wi-Fi which is
generally faster than the 2.4 gigahertz
wireless band of the original console
provided you have a modem that can take
advantage of it
a slim also now supports a Bluetooth 4.0
which is more power efficient and offers
better wireless audio performance
finally the slim supports USB 3.1 which
is up to 2 times as fast as the
originals 3.0 ports speaking of USB the
2 ports in the front are spread out a
little further this time around the
hardware is also a little more power
efficient overall whereas the original
ps4 is ready to consume 250 watts the
slim features 865 watt TDP it's more
power efficient design allows it to run
a bit cooler and quieter as a result on
the front of the console you'll notice
that the light bar has been removed
in its place is a tiny dotted LED which
sits atop the physical power button to
the right is the eject button on the
backside of the unit is a removable
cover that allows you to access the
storage drive in case you ever wanted to
swap out the HDD on the bottom of the
slim are little rubber feet that take
the shape of the PlayStation button
logos if the slim does have one drawback
over the original it's the removal of
the spit of port this can be annoying if
you were planning on connecting a sound
bar to the system that uses an optical
audio connection on the bright side some
small improvements were made to the
controller there is now a light bar at
the front of the touchpad and the
controller now works in a wired mode
when its physic
we plugged in this will allow you to
avoid wireless interference and it also
mitigates controller latency the slim
doesn't make a ton of improvement over
its original incarnation if you already
own a ps4 it doesn't make much sense to
get the slim furthermore if you want a
more powerful PlayStation we suggest you
wait for the pro model in November
regardless the slim still represents a
marked improvement over the original
with its new svelte design for more
PlayStation coverage head on over to
GameSpot comm and subscribe to our
YouTube channel
[Music]
you
you